finite mindset is everything is about
this transaction this listing an
infinite mindset is i may win or lose
this game i may win or lose this
transaction and there'll be another one
and another one and another one and
another one and the goal is not to win
this one the goal is to be better and
better and better and better and better
and what happens is you win more often
yeah
so i uh see and where i struggle with
that honestly is i want to crush it
every time yeah of course of course
you're every time you're a highly
competitive eight personality i get it
but if that's all you do
you you're not going to be in the game
forever
i've been in a long time but this is my
point
in the infinite game
the infinite game the infinite mindset
is about having the strength the will
and the resources which mean will is i
really still enjoy this industry
and the resources i got the money to
stay in the game if you run out of will
you run out of resources you find a
different line of work
right the goal is not to win every game
the goal is to stay in the game as long
as possible and you're more likely to
stay in the game as long as possible if
you're enjoying it and if you're making
money
so uh
but like i said think of those agents
who are better than you whether they're
better marketers or better sales person
or they have they get more
recommendations and again you don't have
to like them you have to thank them and
study them and learn what they're doing
as i said because their strengths are
revealed revealing to you your
weaknesses and sometimes partner with
them because you're actually stronger
together
but hating them is
stupid right
all it does is make you focus on them
rather than focus on yourself all it
does is make you focus and and sit
around with your friends and be like but
they don't do this and they well you're
not doing any of that either you know so
it it puts all your focus in all the
wrong places
it's like you know what it's like uh uh
if any skiers out there
if you ski through trees
every skier knows this if you say don't
hit a tree don't hit a tree don't hit a
tree you hit a tree
because all you're doing is looking at
trees
where
when you're skiing through trees and you
say follow the path follow the path
follow the path you don't hit a tree
because you're only looking at the path
so your mindset is if all you're doing
is focusing on them
then you're you're hitting trees is what
you're doing you're focusing all the
things that make you weak
rather than focusing on all the things
that make you better